مع أكثر من 65000 قدم مربع من
المساحة ومائة وخمسة عشر غرفة ،
قلعة هيرست هي واحدة من
أكبر المنازل في أمريكا وأكثرها عزيزة ،
وقد تم بناء قلعة هيرست من قبل قطب الصحف الأمريكية
ويليام راندولف هيرست في عام 1919
بعد أن ورث 40.000 فدان من
الأراضي الزراعية التي كان سيذهب إليها  شراء
200000 فدان إضافية من الأرض مما يسمح
له بإنشاء نوع مجمع مترامي الأطراف
نادرًا ما نراه حتى يومنا هذا بالإضافة
إلى المنزل الرئيسي la casa grande
يتكون Hearst Castle من ثلاثة
بيوت ضيافة ومسبح خارجي والعديد
من المرافق الأخرى وهي واحدة من أكثر
الغرف شهرة  في قلعة هيرست ،
يوجد حمام سباحة روماني داخلي بمساحة 345 ألف جالون تم
تصميمه على طراز الحمامات الرومانية القديمة
، وقد تم تزيين المسبح بثمانية تماثيل
آلهة الآلهة الرومانية واليونانية
والأبطال ، اشتهر هيرست
بإقامة الحفلات الفخمة واستضافة
شخصيات مهمة في منزله في سان سيميون ونستون
تشرشل.  تشارلي شابلن كاري غرانت
كانا غاربو وكالفين كوليدج
من بين مئات المنازل  uests
تم التبرع بالمنزل إلى ولاية
كاليفورنيا 1958 ويستقبل أكثر من
750.000 زائر كل عام